how does it feel to once again be back
in st louis playing in this prestigious
event it feels great um this is my sixth
time playing so
i think from the first time i've played
to now you know i've seen a lot of
players come and go and a lot of players
still here so
um yeah it's definitely very special
um as a feeling just to have
gone from one of the youngest players in
the event to think that i'm the oldest
player in the event so
there's a there's a lot of history for
me and a lot of great feelings and you
know obviously it's always great just to
be back in st louis feels great this is
my first time playing this tournament
and it's a really strong event and i
think it's a great opportunity for me to
get some experience against all these
great players i'm glad to be back last
time i was here
um is in october so it's been a while
um
but yeah very exciting i actually
haven't played juniors in a while now
it's a little bit weird i guess i'm not
playing the girls section like i usually
am
but i'm very excited for this tournament
i'm really excited to be here and it's
my last time so i've won it
and and on a high note it feels really
nice it's it's a tournament i've been
waiting for and it's a strong field and
i will look forward to playing
definitely very excited
it's quite a
big tournament obviously
and very excited to play all my fellow
competitors it feels amazing st louis is
one of the many places i look forward to
coming back to recently i had this
amazing i had these amazing events one
was a this spring classic group we wish
i won it feels amazing to be back here i
hope my streak continues generally
enjoyed enjoyed playing at the st louis
chess club for for several tournaments
so
it's always nice to
be here
be
here and play play tournaments in st
louis chess club um it's a great honor
great honor and pleasure to be back in
um
my first time was actually last year so
this time just you know trying to do my
best
and hopefully improve upon last year
[Music]